jude karola meeder schwester und ich
haben sich jeweils 25 fakten über mich
auf geschrieben so dass wir am ende
quasi 100 fach oder mich haben leider
waren eigentlich alle fakten irgendwie
gegen mich ich weiß nicht ob es genau
100 fakten sind oder 102 oder 98 auf
jeden fall kommen jetzt eine menge
fakten über milch luca hat angst bei
achterbahnen war in einem lokal in der
ortsgruppe schickt dann sagt er jedes
mal ist er voll und luca ist somit
abstimmt der anstrengendste mensch der
ganzen welt so gerade mit einem
brettspiel mit dem spiel bei den ständig
irgendeine neue regeln findet denn
zurzeit mit dem ich bei meinen eltern
ausgezogen bin stehen in meinem zimmer
einfach fitnessgerät herum luca hast
fliegen denn musikgeschmack ist klar
sagt zwar dass in alle therapien würden
aber eigentlich therapie er immer alle
menschen und gerade auch taxifahrer
wirklich habe in zwei kölner klubs haus
für politiker ist immer mega gewaltigen
carin vogel von der seite oder diesen
kakadu kann ich habe früher wenn ich
doch nicht immer so 20 von diesen süßen
soßen extra bestellt damit wie viel zu
hause haben zum essen ich nutze in
marseille war als servierten luca hat
kein zeitgefühl und kommt immer zu spät
wenn man noch keine frage stellt man vor
zwei wochen oder so schon mal gefragt
hat dann ist
habe ich schon mal gesagt luca wurde mal
von dem hund unser konzept ist kleiner
und die verwundert uns alle sehr dass er
diese gerne mag ich möchte später wenn
ich ein haus habe irgendwo in einem
vorort von hamburg de luca hast du hier
vorher noch nie richtig probiert
wenn der schwamm geschickt dann
unterbricht er einfach und erzählt
irgendetwas was er gerade macht eine
minute lang dass ich jetzt im rutschen
den ball bleibt und danach einem future
combat luca kommen zu jedem
familienessen wirklich zu spät und
müssen manchmal schon ein bisschen
vorbestellen
damit es dann pünktlich da ist und dann
irgendwann mal an kommt aus köln wenn es
irgendwie über 30 grad sind im sommer
fahre ich immer aus köln zu meiner
familie hier nach bielefeld weil sie im
pool haben und da kann man sich dann
abkühlen luca ist so krank habt
ordentlich dass es manchmal nicht mehr
lukrativ als er kennt die fünf stunden
lang im bett stellen sowie sarah julia
und ich luca hast pilze obwohl er
irgendwie die noch nie so richtig
gegessen habe ich habe die beste
schwester der welt gehört nicht möglich
kann kommt immer zu spät also egal wie
ernsten situation unseres karate macht
sich jedes mal drüber lustig muss kommt
immer irgendeinen scheiß kommentare
manchmal gehe ich in der woche jeden tag
ins gym aber manchmal gehe ich dann auch
einfach mal drei wochen kann ich also
ich bin da folgten regelmäßig
[Musik]
seine mutter gefällt sein und gefragt ob
eads sogar weiter als kind früher
frettchen haben und dann kommt jemand
aus geredet und dabei so sauber und
manche kritiker die coolsten haustiere
der ganzen welt ich habe früher mal ein
plastiklöffel aus dem supermarkt geklaut
ist eine große packung wo sie 100 löffel
dran waren weil ich eigentlich noch ein
brauchte und dann habe ich den
mitgenommen zum stand ein eis zu essen
und dann habe ich aber wieder
zurückgebracht nicht antworten basilika
die schlichtung habe ich nicht etwas
gemerkt hat doch immer ich habe
insgesamt erst einen winner fortnight
beziehen können du kannst du kannst
nicht ganz so denkt aber als kind immer
ein bisschen wasser scholl und fand
eigentlich so dass er früher voll
scheiße und erziehung nicht getraut vom
fünf meter turm
wenn ich mal bei mcdonald's essen dann
eigentlich nahezu immer mcnuggets trägt
ist punk dort aus gelangt das nicht
hinbekommen
do kann macht das als kind folge an ihn
gewöhnt hat und dann hat er immer opfer
musste papa immer seine sorten nehmen
diese vorwürfe mit ihr die kann anziehen
konnte mit seine füße haben sind ich
habe mir mal einen kronkorken ins auge
gehauen beim öffnung von dem bier und
habe danach wirklich eine schon lange
gedacht ich sei blind auf diesem auge
gehasst gruselige filme
luca sind die fahrt nach hause im am
lustigsten luca trinkt am allerliebsten
wirklich schlimmes wasser und dieses so
kranken gewann heute bei mcdonald's hat
er sich auch einfach bei mcdonald's ein
stilles wasser geholt ich hasse
kohlensäure kann nicht
schlittschuhlaufen das auto passt ja
immer angst wenn du gut war es da wohl
einige kritik und luca wusste bis vor
sechs monate nicht was trocken ist und
er hat dann einfach richtig angst hatte
ich ihnen das in die haare spricht hat
betrage einlagen in meinen schuhen weil
ich eine fußfehlstellungen knick senk
und ihr ist dass nico hätte gerne einen
hund in einer hässlichen stadt du kannst
erstes handy war ein ganz dickes nur
gehen von sieben tagen kamen neue
klamotten in denen du kannst eigentlich
immer hunger duca braucht länger zu
fertig machen das nicht also kann ich
habe früher im markt nicht erliegen
kommt alle drei teile beim macbook hat
nur 256 gigabyte speicher und deswegen
immer wenn ich irgend etwas neues da
drauf packen würde das herunterladen
will muss sich erst noch alte dateien
löschen
zwar sehr selten aber manchmal kann man
auch echt gute gespräche er hetzt luc
otten bei plus platz gefunden musste
dann ist viel geld für ein taxi
bezahlung irgendwie komme ich habe
übelste polder kann es nicht ab wenn
gerade nichts zu tun der ironischen
luca ruft ein so gut wie nie normal an
sondern immer nur bei pace damit richtig
oft wenn irgendwo es richtig laut das
internet hätte ja eigentlich gar nichts
zu sagen weil die einfach nur zeigen
müssen am liebsten möchte ich später
wenn ich ein eigenes haus habe also
einen riesigen garten haben wo dann
irgendwie ein volleyballfeld ist und
ihnen noch ein basketballplatz
vielleicht auch ein fußballtor
wer trinkt gar keinen kaffee ich fliege
nächstes wochenende los angeles geglaubt
gerne die wird sie von anderen macht sie
dann in seine skepsis orientiert wenn du
keine fotos bearbeiten
luca ist als kind mal auf eine kirche
klettere ich habe keine klimaanlage in
meiner wohnung in köln
deswegen stehe ich da jedem sommer jedes
jahr luca hat manchmal so ganz komische
gedanken auf einmal dass man sich dann
auf einmal fragt warum fliegen in irgend
eine bestimmte richtung fliegen oder
sonstwie chef die luft trage durch den
ganzen tag können wir treibt immer wenn
er eine geschichte erzählt was passiert
ist oder so er bereit ist einfach jedes
mal lukas notsituation so gar nicht
hilfreich zum beispiel waren wir
österreich und ich habe hier im hotel
verlaufen und dann habe ich eben
irgendwie gesagt bewertet nicht einfach
abholen kann oder ob er weiß wo es ist
und welchen standort vom hotel der so
gar nicht gewusst ich bin den golden
state fällen luca hat den titel ist wenn
er sich einmal etwas in den kopf gesetzt
hat das ist dann so schnell wie möglich
passieren kann ist wenn trost es gibt
diesen freunden auf dem iphone wo man
seine freunde orten kann und gab es dann
doch für uns alle ausgestellt weil
carola den amazon hat gestartet und so
angekettet wenn luca gesagt und das ist
schon unterwegs sich auf der freunde
gesehen hat dass er noch zu hause sein
aktuelles lieblingsvideo ist nice vor
ort vom break lukas schlechten form ist
einer der größten anti raucher die
können locker ich habe mal einen
verletzten vogel aufgezogen haben die
börsen haben ja wie meine sonnenbrille
einmal beim small and kaputt gemacht und
danach habe ich mir neu gekauft habe die
dann in amsterdam verloren und seitdem
trage ich eine 5 dollar
sonnenbrille aus miami
luca ist total um regelmäßig und richtig
komisch nur zeit und dann richtig
richtig viel auf einmal ich habe
insgesamt neun badehose trägt
[Musik]
mit luca telefoniert dann sagt einfach
nicht schön ist wenn er auflegt eine
frau beleidigt
luca manchmal einfach eiskalt zu mir
würde das lieber einen kleinen bruder
gehabt hätte meine weisheitszähne
mussten eigentlich nicht raus ich habe
sie allerdings trotzdem rausnehmen
lassen weil es jetzt irgendwie echt
schwieriger ist lukas spitzname ist
lukas mit einem so lautet man kann
menschen die so lauten ich wiege genau
80 kilo das war's jetzt ja allerdings
auch mit den hundert akten über mich
gesagt ich weiß jetzt genau 100 fahren
oder irgendwie 99 oder 103 oder so die
sind alle dummen können leider nicht
zählen wenn euch das video gefallen hat
das gerne mal ein leichter vielleicht
schaffen wir ja 100 likes wegen hundert
akten und ich gebe mich jetzt vergraben